foreign
I first saw the movie Jaws when I was
about eight years old egged on by a
friend's older sister
I was terrified
the image of that shark haunted me I saw
it everywhere
I wouldn't go into the ocean or the pool
for a solid year
I avoided even the bathtub for weeks
fast forward a few years my family is on
vacation on the coast I'm still scared
of swimming but it's more of a jump at
every noise scared than outright
aversion
somehow despite that I end up on an
introductory scuba course
the water is calm and warm I'm actually
having a great time
and then I see it
a shock
the adrenaline starts pumping I gasp
but with my next exhale the fear
disappears
this is what I've been so scared of
this Bears almost no resemblance to Jaws
it's incredible
terrifying
can we all agree
so often the fiction is scarier than the
reality
think of flying
clowns
and as I can personally attest public
speaking
let me add one more to the list
nuclear power
so this isn't actually a talk about fear
it's a talk about how our irrational
fiction of nuclear power and things like
it affects our very real public policy
our demand for electricity is going up
to 2050. no matter which forecast you
look at
we are combating warmer Summers colder
Winters and increasing electrification
when we turn to supply it starts to
paint a scary picture and it gets worse
if we remove coal as a source of
electricity as current trends suggest we
will
demand is going to outpace supply by a
large amount
people from developing countries can
tell you what this means
in South Africa where I'm from they call
it load shedding they turn off the power
by ZIP code on a scheduled basis because
there isn't enough of it
you have to plan out when to charge your
phone
open your business
operate on patients
it cripples an economy
so we have to close the gap
Renewables are great but insufficient
alone their production tends to
fluctuate and they often need a lot of
Real Estate
they need a more stable compact
complement
and that complement also needs to be
clean safe and affordable
that is when nuclear power comes in
now I know what you're thinking nuclear
power it's too dangerous to be used look
at Chernobyl
in fact 2021 polls suggests around half
of Americans agree with that statement
it perhaps isn't surprising given that
the most Salient image we have of a
nuclear power plant operator is this
[Laughter]
to be perfectly honest I used to be in
that camp until I spent two years
working in the industry as a consultant
buy the numbers nuclear power is
actually one of the safest sources of
electricity
its death rate is 98 lower than gas and
nearly a hundred percent lower than coal
nuclear power is safe
still
major incidents Loom large we frequently
see them rehashed in Hollywood
it's Jaws all over again
the fictional story sells tickets
but it misrepresents a lot of the facts
when you boil it down there are really
two types of incident
those driven by technical breakdown and
those by human error
take Chernobyl
it was built in the 70s and 80s using a
design the rest of the world had
abandoned for good reason
the design itself was inherently
unstable the safety feature meant to
stop the reaction instead spit it up
it was a matter of time until something
went wrong
we can contrast this with Fukushima
which is instead a tale of human error
the reactor design at Fukushima was
sound it survived the earthquake without
major damage the issue was the tsunami
but 18 years before the incident new
research suggested that that plant was
vulnerable to a tsunami
the international agency recommended a
higher barrier but the local operator
and regulator did nothing
it wasn't the technology itself that was
so dangerous
it was the humans that chose to ignore
prescient advice
these days designs are highly regulated
and many next-gen designs include
passive safety features that mean there
is no need for human intervention
think more Jetsons than Simpsons
but beyond design Fukushima also shows
us that scenario testing and training
are critical
it sounds like a tall order but France
has proved it can be done
France generates over 70 percent of
their power from nuclear energy but has
never had an incident that impacted
surrounding communities
they have proved that it is possible to
consistently operate nuclear power
plants in a safe way
they've also shown us better ways to
deal with used nuclear fuel
nuclear waste causes a lot of protests
in the U.S
and understandably so it sounds scary
and people don't like the idea of it
being buried in their backyard
but France has figured out how to
recycle the vast majority of this waste
leaving less than five percent to be
buried in sealed containers
recycling isn't perfect but it's a very
good start
nuclear power is clean and safe
however at that point this point I have
to acknowledge that there is an economic
reality to consider this is something
that politicians bring up all the time
and it's true new builds can be
expensive
but those costs could come down
dramatically
South Korea's kepco for instance
recently built a plant in the UAE that
cost less than 60 percent the most
recent new build in the US
they didn't cut corners or use cheaper
materials
they reduced costs through supply chain
efficiency
next-gen designs are looking to capture
that efficiency too by designing smaller
reactors that can be Factory produced
and stacked
additionally once the plant is up and
running nuclear power is actually a
remarkably cheap source of electricity
it is cheaper than coal or gas it may
even be competitive with wind and solar
once you add in their need for storage
nuclear power is Affordable it is safe
and it is clean
why does that matter
as I said earlier our demand for
electricity is eclipsing our ability to
supply it we have to find new sources of
clean power
part nuclear has not been part of that
discussion in fact
in many Western economies we have been
closing nuclear power plants for the
past two decades and there are more
slated to close in the years to come
why
I'd argue that in many regions it stems
from politicians and activists buying in
to the Jaws story of nuclear
I hope by now that I have convinced you
that that is not the case and that
nuclear is actually part of the solution
to a much bigger problem
so what can we do
for those of you headed into politics I
ask that you vote in favor of nuclear
investors and utilities I ask that you
finance it
for the rest of us the best thing you
can do is spread the word be a voice in
favor instead of a voice against
choose not to protest the next time your
utilities suggests building a nuclear
plant in fact be an advocate and educate
your neighbors
we cannot let fear based on fiction
dictate policy in reality
imagine what we could do as a society
with a limitless source of clean cheap
power
in my home country it would make a huge
difference
what would it mean for yours
thank you
[Music]